alright guys welcome back thank you for
joining us at the fall movie previews
we're the schmoes and of course we're
joined by Jeremy John's thanks for being
a dream not a problem it's actually on
my channel so alright so this should
never be in here guys I right here with
the schmoes I think you have a pretty
good month of fall movies alright let's
figure it out alright so November 4th
I'm take my words back you have
something with Ellen Barkin and Demi
Moore I think we are in 1993 ago I am an
ER you kiddo hikers go ahead I thought
you said I had a good my I'm taking the
Ripper no here you go you got an
animation and those always do a while
those ones yeah Puss in Boots destiny
he actually does look funny when I when
I saw the first trailer I was like are I
spin off we'll see but that's how the
final trailer and fun trailer actually
does look funny cuz I know if I can tell
that cat that people like yeah yeah
that's yeah not real catch it but
you know what cats do stuff and you're
like oh that's funny they should make a
character that walks and talks and those
that and they did you can call me creepy
that damn cat is so cute and the voice
is fitted so fervently I want to see
this movie yeah yeah the nascent xB does
very well in this one works Puss in
Boots
I think few marks has a hit on their
hands obviously so you're saying you
want to arrive on the show it's inside a
building there's the most advanced
security and is guarded by FBI agents 24
hours a day we don't know how to steal I
don't know everyone looks funny Murphy
yeah I've been Murphy to be the funny
one he looks like annoying it looks like
if this movie came out in 2001 I'd be
all right yeah doing memories to get
dropped off every morning for day care
back in a poem and coming out was very
scary someone doesn't cause seizures
why'd you bear me out maybe Murphy is
kind of like Brett Favre to me where I
wanted to keep coming back and I hope he
keeps doing well but you just don't know
anymore I'm rooting for you Eddie yes
it's like the Italian Job meets meets
die hard means neither I don't want you
talking me for the rest of the robbery
this is why I was saying you're lucky to
have November because November 9
Jay Edgar comes out yes and that's the
Clint Eastwood directed film with
Leonardo DiCaprio Arnie hammer it is an
Oscar movie I don't even know anything
about it that tight so you just gonna be
offered house for sale that's accurate
Leo best director Clint Eastwood Best
Picture it's gonna happen um I'm looking
forward to it I need to see it and it's
a course based on J Edgar Hoover the
popular cross-dressing FBI had mentioned
in ghostbusters and it's got Artie
Hammer it and he's only going to play
one person in this movie it's a you know
it's something we do you don't see a
trailer yet use do you want to see the
movie this better think it shows you the
heavyweights up and nothing is going up
against it
if there is one human who could lead
them against etherion it would be theses
and I take my words back because
something I definitely want to see that
we can that's the Immortals that is like
the cool version of Clash of the Titans
I hope it's cool
it's gonna be yeah I hope you know
finish your thought you see the fall
what did I say the one we the fall no
see that movie me don't tell you tarsem
is a great director oh really
yeah a little Rams tone change and then
you have you know the new Superman is a
starring Mickey Rourke is in this film
this is going to be a cool feeling
guarantee that I hope it you do it
you're saying you recommend a cool I
know it it I may be proven wrong but
this looks like the 300 movie that's not
300 makes this Clash of the Titans
they're trying again that's the
difference though Zack Snyder and parson
were two different directors of them the
great either way you're gonna leave the
theater wanting to do a sit-up as well
but I will say it's not going to be the
worst movie even if it's stinks it won't
be the worst movie that weekend cuz Jack
and Jill comes out the same weakness huh
don't know you're getting fat up in your
hair doesn't realize it needs to cover
more face okay and that is going to be
one of the worst movies of the Ben
Franklin put on a way to start your
plays in this backyard it's gonna happen
to Adam Sandler what happened to you
still makes money yeah I guess and look
at her I see me when I look at her I see
me to it yeah and Jim alright
November 18th month is pretty good so
far remember 18 you got happy feet -
please mommy the boy seeks out I hear
truth okay it's another movie that could
be a lot of fun yeah I mean yeah it's
not gonna be like we're not like Puss in
Boots about it but it is the new
standard yeah yeah well I guess I'm full
animated movies that sprung off of shrek
but you know we'll say I think it's good
right it's gonna be better in puss but I
don't know I don't know I I either
wanted to meet it I'm done with peg
- after Happy Feet - you have a movie
called Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy I know
how fury a film thing has actually
excited about this film it's with Gary
Oldman Colin Firth okay and Tom Hardy
Wow
most guys come to the mode is one of
five yeah you changed from the Tinker
Tailor Soldier Spy I don't know what I'm
a few of those things I tell you one
thing I don't know anything about it but
from those names I don't care the title
on scene if I'm gonna call the League of
Awesome yeah and then you're you go
Jeremy have at it guys can talk about
this the Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn
Part 1 with Twilight I just know and
that's what I don't lay it on the store
I pick up the sword I'm like let's go to
town let's have some fun let's do some
London riots on one movie are you a fan
of Twilight no but I'm a fan of what I
get to say about Twilight all right but
I know I can say about Twilight be 100%
correct I get wrapped up in those damn
movies hungry Maria Bella
I'm on your team sweetie you're gonna
die for me it's like I'm not the fan
base for this stupid but I'll tell
you know I know people are gonna love it
and it's probably gonna rap out make
millions and millions of dollars if you
love it you should subscribe to this
channel I'm just saying yeah
to RCC's movie actually does come out
and that's Hugo oh very interesting it's
not a typical you're not gonna sell a
baseball best to the head in this one
yeah it's really funny about that that
was the one where Eber said I'll support
3d when someone like Scorsese does and
Scorsese films and Ebert was like
alright I'm not remaking on that I still
hate it I just didn't think he did you
go
and then the Muppets yeah sorry
yeah Jason Seagal illegal toggle he
basically reinvented the whole franchise
and I'm rootin for him to me Adam's
right yeah any items favorite love your
report animal
Oh Kermit yeah trim it's like tonic but
the Muppets
and that's how you end it there's some
quality and there you have Eastwood
directing you have Scorsese directing
you have the tackler in there you have
Tom Hardy in there and yet Muppet in
mufon's that's a serious month man yep
it's a serious month and you have
Twilight which is it is just going to
suck but my video will be fun I love
swelling I love November Happy
Thanksgiving everybody thanks for
watching this that's November check out
December's coming on their channel if
you're not subscribed to them subscribe
to them if you're not subscribed to me
that how you get your magical tell us
your secret wizard yeah